j'avais rendez vous avec gérard monsieur
gérard viau et sa femme pour une prise
de vue dans leur cuisine
je suis arrivé chez eux j'ai frappé on
m'a entrouvert la porte avec quand même
la petite barrette et on m'a dit on ne
veut pas être photographiés j'étais un
peu surpris je négocie un petit peu ce
que je m'étais trompé dans le rendez
vous et puis déçu je repartis dans la
rue quelques jours plus tard c'est
michel michel loisel qui m'appellent
pour photographier sa femme dans la
cuisine
aïe j'arrive chez lui je prends tes
installe on prend un t2 t3 t4 en parle
pas de la prise de vue à un coup de
téléphone sonne
michel pas répondre et à peine eu le
temps de terminer ma tasse de thé que
le gérard arrivent vous le voyez content
hilare satisfait du tour pendable qu'il
venait de faire à sa nièce qui s'étaient
opposés parce qu'ils viennent se faire
photographier pourquoi gérard donne et
il tend à se faire photographier parce
qu'il voulait participer comme les
autres habitants de son quartier
un récit photographique qui petit à
petit s'affichait sur les murs a cité je
suis photographe au labomylette non
madame pas la mobylette le labomylette
labo pour laboratoires milette pour
mobiles c'est donc un petit laboratoire
mobile qui s'installe dans le paysage un
croisement de route une rue un quartier
une entreprise
et qui jour après jour affiche les
personnes pas à pas pour constituer un
récit collective c'est à ça que gérard
voulez participer
alors petit à petit les images vont
animer la rue
ces photographies change le regard qu'on
porte sur nos voisins et elle provoque
les rencontres le labomylette c'est un
espace de liberté
celui d'exposer d'abord mais aussi de
s'exposer en dépassant le plaisir qu'on
a de se voir en photo pour participer un
récit collectif
alors comment est venue cette iv et bien
je crois que c'est parce que je suis
issu d'une famille d'immigrants juifs
polonais et roumains ou la question dans
ma famille a toujours été l'intégration
je cite ma tante dorina tu te rends
compte
on a mis trois mois et demi à venir
jusqu'en france à pied
on a passé les frontières qui étaient
interdites pour nous il fallait se
cacher
est arrivé en france on devait rejoindre
son grand père était déjà là alors on
l'a appelé au téléphone
et pendant que mon téléphone est est
juste à la faune
un policier s'est approché nous mais
qu'est ce que tu voulais qu'on fasse et
m'attendent de dire on s'est embrassés
sur la bouche
c'était l'histoire la plus fantastique
qu'ils n'avaient jamais vécu malgré tout
le tragique de leur histoire dans les
pays
c'était aussi un premier geste une
première façon de s'intégrer dans la
population française
en pratiquement frenchkiss je crois que
c'est pour ça que j'ai été amené à créer
le labomylette alors un jour je suis
sorti de chez moi j'ai été acheté un
appareil photo puis je suis rentré chez
moi j'ai mis au placard pendant quelques
années
et puis sur sorti de chez moi j'ai pris
mon appareil photo j'ai photographié mon
jardin pendant quelques années ce
toxique et petit à petit j'ai
photographié les jardins des doutes les
champs les haies les cailloux qui
émergent du sol les racines jusqu'à ce
que je me retrouve dans une usine pour
photographier
peut-être les gens qui travaillaient
alors j'ai posé mon appareil sur un pied
et j'ai attendu que quelqu'un passe
yep je l'avais aujourd'hui je
photographie les gens au quotidien et je
crois que c'est ça qui répond à mon
désir d'intégration ainsi vont se
côtoyer sur les murs si vous avez bien
suivi les bikers tatouer les slameurs
les rappeurs les carmélites où les chefs
de choeur les passants dit pas c'est que
personne ne connaît encore les personnes
habitant sur le perron de leurs portes
alors fenêtre pour regarder les passants
qui passaient que personne ne connaît
vraiment mais moi ce que j'aime par
dessus tout faire c'est aller dans les
arrière boutiques et révéler ce qui s'y
trouve
ou alors dans les ateliers on bricole
ses passions ou alors les gens au
travail et ceux qui cultivent leur
jardin ou alors ceux qui travaillent et
ceux qui cultivent leur jardin encore
et puis ceux qui travaillent et ceux qui
travaillent et ceux qui travaillent
comme vous pause café calva
et ça continue jusqu'à ce que j'aie
puise les habitudes du quartier et voir
mes propres habitudes à moi aussi
ainsi vont se croiser sur les murs d
intimité
depuis la naissance jusqu'à la mort
exposé en grand format c'est quelque
chose de très courant aujourd'hui
l'originalité du labomylette repose sur
une petite chose exposer son travail au
fur et à mesure situation assez
inconfortable pour les personnes qui le
pratiquent
mais au bout du compte c'est ça qui
permet aux personnes de laisser germer
l'envi
de participer et de s'exposer dans un
récit collectif
en définitive le labomylette c'est un
catalyseur de rencontre alors suite à
son passage j'ai pu constater que de
nombreuses associations d'habitants se
sont créé des collectifs de village
aussi et je vois aussi les demandes des
collectivités des institutions soit pour
fédérer les habitants autour d'un
développement social local soit sur un
projet de développement durable soit
dans une entreprise pour la prévention
des risques psychosociaux
bref je réalise avec ça que londres
qu'on a construit
on fait très attention à notre confrère
nous isole et nous confine chez nous peu
de gens pratiquent ou mettent en
pratique le lien social qui existe
pourtant
eh bien je crois que il n'est pas le
seul mais le labomylette donne
consistance à ce lien dans les lieux
publics
c'est un terreau fertile
qui permet aux racines du lien de
poussée en dehors des peaux qui sont
situées derrière leurs fenêtres
vous pouvez faire comme nous puisque
nous sommes un collectif d labomylette
avec des crayons et pinceaux votre
ordinateur si vous êtes infographe et
mon rêve ce serait que le mot
labomylette commença à se conjuguer jeu
là comme il est
tu labomylette il la pop il est nous
labeaume il et on vous la mobilité et
j'espère bien que vous labeaume
illettrés